[Music]  okay what's your name Stephanie and  where are you from Los Angeles what's  been your biggest obstacle and how'd you  get through it  my biggest obstacle  tough question I have to pause for a  while on that one that's okay I couldn't  turn off the camera yeah whenever you  ready okay I think it's kind of personal  but I'll share it with you that I think  the biggest obstacle that I had to get  through was getting sober  about eight years ago and it was quite  difficult but it's been a really great  experience since and I think what helped  me get through it the most was the  support of family and friends I know  without that support so yeah today  life's pretty good  still has its challenges and  but it's easier to get through through  them clearly with a clear head and clear  mind and a spiritual practice so yeah  [Music]